c'est un véritable fléau pour le val de
loire et les jardiniers des grands sites
touristiques la pyrale du buis cette
petite pêche univers tu venu d'asie elle
se nourrit exclusivement de feuilles de
bruit il faut donc surveiller et traité
pour gérer cette invasion grandissante
illustration ce soir dans les jardins du
château de villandry et victimes eux
aussi de la voracité des insectes
denis gagné france ici - s c'est encore
acceptable sa fin c'est acceptable
triste constat de l'invasion de la
pyrale qui fait autant de dégâts dans
les bruits une petite chenille
asiatiques qui envahit la france depuis
2007 pour le rang portugaise chef
jardinier de villandry qui possède 15 km
linéaires de l'arbuste avec ses dix
équipiers c'est une veille quotidienne
pendant quelques mois un cycle de du
papillon et rouleur de ff et de deux
mois c'est à dire que la chenille passe
tout l'hiver
bien caché dans un cocon dans les
feuilles de lui donc là elle est
intouchable dès le mois de mars dès les
premiers rayons du soleil
elle ressort elle commence à manger là
on est parti pour deux mois donc sur un
souffle de moi d'ailleurs à un mois
trois quatre semaines ça de chenilles
elle repasse en papillon un couple mort
ponte et on part donc voilà de de mars à
septembre octobre on est soumis à la
pression de cette chaude la voici cette
spirale particulièrement vorace et quand
elles sont nombreuses dans un arbuste
elles peuvent dévorer l'ensemble du
feuillage en 48 heures beaucoup de
fausses bonnes idées pour les supprimer
à villandry on a fait un choix plutôt
efficace cas le bruit c'est 80 % des
structures végétales des célèbres
jardins n'a de la présence partout donc
voilà à nous d'être vraiment vigilants
et de limiter la prolifération de cette
chenille par utilisation d'un d'un
produit utilisé pour la culture
biologique
donc c'est sous la forme d'une poudre
c'est une bactérie que l'on pulvérise
sur le bruit la chenille ingère cette
bactérie en mangeant les feuilles et
cette bactérie un effet coupe faim sur
la chaîne in donc elle meurt au bout de
24 48 heures nombreux sont les
particuliers qui ont vu leurs billets
être attaquée cet été par ces chenilles
qui deviennent des papillons de nuit
coupez l'arbuste à la moitié est
vaporisée cette bactérie le bacillus
serait le meilleur des traitements mais
en 2017
seule la bretagne la normandie sont plus
ou moins épargné le sud de la france
étant particulièrement touchés